and a special thanks to representative
Omar of Minnesota
oh oh I forgot
she doesn't like Israel I forgot I'm so
sorry
oh no she doesn't like Israel does she
oh please I apologize
[Applause]
if implemented the Democrats radical
agenda would destroy our economy
our country and very well could leave
Israel out there all by yourselves can't
do that never before has a major
political party been more outside the
American mainstream than the Democrats
of today they have become the party of
high taxes open borders late-term
abortion crime witch hunts and delusions
and now the Democrats have even allowed
the terrible scourge of anti-semitism to
take root in their party and in their
country and the governor